[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime out lore and welcome to
another Dragon Ball super video before
we get started I want to thank all of
you who have been supporting our Dragon
Ball super videos and commenting that
you want to see more we weren't sure at
first whether our audience here on the
channel was interested in Dragon Ball
super content but we received a lot of
comments from you guys telling us that
you enjoy it and want to see more and
that really means a lot to us in this
video I will be talking about something
that I've been thinking about a lot as
I've been watching the latest episodes
of Dragon Ball super and of course if
you aren't caught up to the anime be
warned that this video will contain
spoilers to be specific freezes actions
in the last few episodes including his
decision to betray Frost
his decision to help Goku by giving him
some of his own energy and his decision
to eliminate kebab from universe 6
even after Vegeta saved him just moments
earlier have driven home an important
point about Frieza the fact is that
Frieza might actually end up being one
of universe sevens MVPs when it comes to
winning the tournament of power when it
was first announced that Frieza would be
revived for the tournament many people
including myself thought this was a
strange decision and many argued that
SEL would have been a better choice
since he was far more powerful than
Frieza
in Dragon Ball Z and because Sal
possesses both Saiyan DNA and DNA from
frieza's race his potential to evolve
and perhaps even develop a golden form
like Frieza was always there on top of
that Sal had organized his own
tournament in Dragon Ball Z known as the
Cell Games so not only is he a strong
fighter determined to prove his strength
but he is also a big fan of tournaments
and he loves winning so clearly he would
have been a great asset to the universe
17 but as Dragon Ball super has gone on
I've become more and more convinced that
Frieza was in fact the perfect choice
for the tournament of power we have to
remember that cell was primarily
interested in his
own entertainment and proving that he
himself is the strongest fighter he had
no greater ambitions other than that if
he had been in the tournament of power
Sal would have been primarily interested
in having a good time fighting and
proving that he alone is the strongest
the problem with that is simple the
tournament of power is structured in a
way that the man's teamwork it is not
about who is the strongest fighter
individually but about which team can
work together most effectively and used
the best strategies to outmaneuver rival
teams cell is a vein and his only goal
is to prove himself as the strongest
most perfect fighter if he came to
realize that he could not eliminate the
competition alone this would be a giant
blow to cells massive ego and he likely
would not have been able to put that ego
aside in order to work together when his
old rivals from universe 7 to win the
tournament so what about Frieza he is
also vain and has an inflated ego for
sure and he certainly does not like the
other members of the universe 17 and yet
Frieza has showed himself to be a
valuable member of the team time and
time again even helping his arch-nemesis
Goku while betraying a member of his own
race frost but more than that Frieza has
shown himself to be willing to do the
dirty work that the other members of his
team are not willing to do Vegeta saves
kebab because as a saying he feels some
sort of compassion for a member of his
race even though Kaba is fighting for a
rival universe earlier in the series
Goku allowed cauliflower and kale to get
away in order to recover so that he
could face off against them when they
were at full strength and this is a
problem that many Saiyans and of course
CEL share they want to prove that they
are the strongest fighters and they're
willing to let their enemies recover or
get stronger because they want to face
the biggest challenge possible but
whether we as viewers like Kaabah
Khalifa and kale as characters aside
this is an elimination
tournament the losing teams will have
their entire universe erased their
families friends everyone they ever knew
gone forever if we look at it from a
practical perspective there is no room
for compassion here if the lives of
everyone you've ever known rest on you
winning this tournament everyone who is
fighting for another universe is your
enemy Frieza is aware of this and he
isn't afraid to do the dirty work that
the Saiyans and other members of
universe summon refused to do think
about it what if after Vegeta saved
Kaaba Kaaba somehow got in the way of
the universe seven team and cost them
the victory there is no guarantee that
if universe 7 loses universe six will
win and then wish universe seven back to
life with the super Dragon Balls and
vice versa there is no guarantee that a
few number six loses universe seven will
automatically win and wish the other
universe back there are other universes
in play here and even the smallest risk
one single wrong move could lead to the
destruction of everyone you love and
care about this is no joke and there is
no room for error here
there is no room for compassion towards
your rivals Frieza might be vain but
unlike the Saiyans and cell he has a
higher goal than simply being the
strongest fighter Frieza wants to be the
Emperor of the universe but for that to
happen
he must ensure that there is a universe
for him to rule in the first place so he
will do whatever it takes to keep
universe 7 from being erased this
doesn't mean that Frieza is now a good
guy it doesn't mean that he now likes
the other members of his team to the
contrary I am sure Frieza will try to
get his revenge on Goku and the others
the first chance he gets his plan is to
use the super Dragon Balls to become
more powerful than even the divine
beings but this can happen only after he
makes sure that universe 7 isn't erased
this is why Frieza was the perfect
choice for the tournament of power he is
strong ruthless
devious he will do whatever it takes to
get his way he will do what needs to be
done to win even when the others aren't
willing to when Goku or Gohan or someone
else find themselves morally conflicted
about what to do and they hesitate
Frieza will step up and do what needs to
be done to win I find it ironic that in
this case a villain might turn out to be
the biggest asset to the universe 17
precisely because he is a villain and
doesn't suffer from the same moral
limitations that the heroes do it's
ironic but it is also very interesting
in life things are often complicated
rather than simple and in times of war
for example even good people find
themselves having to do bad things in
order to win and survive I really like
the Dragon Ball super is exploring these
types of issues more than any Ball Z did
and I like that this makes us who are
watching wonder how far we would go for
the greater good what would we be
willing to do to save our entire
universe and everyone we love let me
know your thoughts down in the comments
but I think that I just might be closer
to Frieza on this issue I believe that
in the end I would do whatever it takes
to protect the people I care about even
if that means showing no mercy to my
rivals do you agree disagree do you
think that Frieza could turn out to be
one of the MVPs for universe 7 because
he is willing to do whatever it takes as
your opinion of Frieza being chosen for
the tournament change as the episodes
have gone on let me know down below if
you enjoyed this video and want to see
more be sure to hit that like button to
let me know and if you are new to the
channel don't forget to subscribe and
click that notification bell as always
thank you so much for watching I want to
give a big thank you to my friend Kid
Kaiping out I also want to give a big
thank you to all of our anime upper
patrons for supporting the channel so
that we can keep doing what we do
including Christian Fleur
Urbano third-strike Sinead OH the one
and only Gilgamesh
original link also big thank you to all
of our former patrons and if you'd like
to consider supporting the channel on
patreon link is in the description
finally a really good friend of mine and
one of my personal favorite youtubers
NOx Taku made a really interesting
Dragon Ball super video the other day by
the way I don't say that he is one of my
favourite youtubers because he's my
friend I say it because he is an
absolutely hilarious content creator his
latest Dragon Ball super video was about
the Goku vs. Gian fight but here's the
catch
NOx Taku is not actually a Dragon Ball
super fan and he doesn't even walk to
show so he made a sarcastic commentary
of the fight made by a non VBS fan if
you're a Dragon Ball super fan and have
a sense of humor I definitely recommend
checking this out it is absolutely
hilarious if you decide to check it out
the link is in the description and feel
free to tell him that his waifu is trash
you'll know what you mean
feel free to let me know what type of
Dragon Ball super video you want to see
next would you like to see commentary
videos Theory videos character analyses
fact we do it all here at anime out bro
so let me know what you would like to
see about Dragon Ball super and I will
do my best to deliver and until next
time see us bass cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]